[Music]
and when 2022 rolled around many out
there looking for a home wonder if the
market would ever slow down but one
industry expert says the first two-month
show is getting more and more
competitive joe mohler joining us near
the durango curve with the impact on
buyers hi joe
hey there brian yeah the expert says if
you're going to be trying to buy a home
in the near future it's going to be
tough for quite a while buyers are
having to get pretty creative in this
market
i did not expect vegas to get that
competitive john bellisteros came to
vegas from the bay area my realtor she
was kind enough to let us know that we
are in a good position but maybe a
little bit more might help after losing
a bidding war on another home they
closed on this northwest valley home we
still offered five percent more he paid
forty thousand dollars over asking price
it was quite surprising but we were
coming from the bay area you're going to
have equity in 2021 values were up more
than 20 percent many were wondering what
2022 would bring roughly 2 percent per
month is what we've been seeing as as
annual appreciation experts expected
values to go up ten to twelve percent
this year if this continues at two
percent a month that would be twenty
four percent coldwell banker ceo bob
hamrick says so far there are no signs
of it slowing down inventory has been
going down by about a hundred properties
a week
to where we're about two thousand single
family residences on the market before
the pandemic they're on average about
five thousand homes on the market
hamrick says buyers especially first
time home buyers need to be creative and
try and get extra cash to offer above
asking when they see the home that they
want today they need to make an offer on
it immediately malisteros tried to not
get too attached to any home even though
we were again in
a strong position to pay cash and maybe
a little bit more than asking
everything is still up in the air you
never know
hamrick says writing a personal letter
to the seller may help in some cases as
well make it a little bit more
personable both of them i also talked to
about being prepared to make multiple
offers on a number of homes that could
get you into at least one of them
reporting live in the southwest valley
this evening joe muller live local now
and we are getting a closer look now at
how federal dollars will be used here in
nevada in the effort to create more
affordable housing now the governor's
office tells us that 300 million dollars
will go to making new housing for
low-income families 130 million will go
to fixing up existing housing and then
40 million will go to buying nearly 100
acres of land for new housing and 30
million will go to incentive programs
trying to drop the price of those new
homes